this is an unbelievable story the Texas
Attorney General Ken Paxton
fled his home in a truck to avoid being
handed a subpoena imagine the imagery of
this CNBC has a good and simple and
straightforward write-up of this Texas
AG Ken Paxton fled home with his wife to
avoid a subpoena in an abortion case
according to a court filing released
earlier this week Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton allegedly fled his home with
his wife to avoid being served a
subpoena according to a sworn affidavit
The subpoena ordered the Republican
attorney general to appear and testify
in a civil lawsuit in which multiple
texas-based non-profits want to resume
helping pregnant residents obtain
abortions in other states a federal
judge quashed The subpoena Paxton on
Twitter claimed he was showing concern
for his family and later said that the
process server the process server is the
individual who delivers the subpoena is
lucky this situation did not escalate
further that's a quote
packs look at these details Paxton ran
from the garage or garage of some say
Paxton ran from the garage of his home
in McKinney Texas into a truck driven by
his wife state senator Angela Paxton
while refusing to accept the documents
from a process server according to the
affidavit filed in court the paxtons
drove away without taking the documents
which were left on the ground by the
house according to the process server
federal judge Robert Pittman granted a
motion Tuesday to quash The subpoena
Paxton argued The subpoena was
unwarranted because none of the
requisites for making or enforcing such
a demand have been satisfied in a
statement Tuesday Paxton accused the
server of posing a threat by charging
Adam and yelling unintelligibly oh my
goodness this is the guy who was
indicted for felony Securities fraud
charges uh years ago
hasn't faced consequences hasn't been
put on trial
uh he still won his Republican primary
and remember as long as it's not a
Democrat Republican voters don't care
what these people do they claim to be
for Law and Order part of Law and Order
is listen
uh illegally created and obtained
subpoena
delivered by a process server a
legitimate process server
and you just run away and jump into a
truck and drive away
that's not Law and Order and again the
Law and Order crowd adhering to the
principle of well Law and Order for
everybody else this is a characteristic
of authoritarianism there is no rules
for the Insiders and the cronies and as
I read this story and as I think about
the perspective of these individuals on
what Law and Order means to them and I
don't mean to them for society I mean to
them when they are the ones involved
with the judicial system it really is
reminiscent of Putin's Russia
and
there's a cartoonish nature for sure
here of Paxton running away and jumping
you know it's Texas we probably had a
belt buckle that was huge and he runs
and jumps into a pickup truck I get it
the imagery is cartoonish the imagery is
funny to some degree but the real story
here is the authoritarian nature of Law
and Order for everybody else and in fact
using the justice system and law
enforcement to their advantage as tools
when it's for other people
and then when it comes to them they just
say no it was a little illegitimate or
I'm going to jump into a truck and run
away it's really the same thing with the
Trump search warrant at Mar-A-Lago which
is hey you know what we back the blue
The Thin Blue Line support the police
except when it's the capitol police at
the Trump riots well in that case it was
the protesters by which you know they
mean Riders who are actually the heroes
and oh no support law enforcement are
great all these great people
they get a legal search warrant signed
off on by the Attorney General by the
FBI director by a judge they go to
Trump's house and they get the stuff
that they're entitled to get oh no no no
no no now it's not about support law
enforcement now it's law enforcement has
been weaponized by Biden even though
Biden had nothing to do with that search
warrant that's the theme and it's an
authoritarian theme that we should all
be very careful about and very scared of
legitimately it's not a slippery slope
thing it's
we should be scared now because of how
they are willing to abandon every single
one of these principles as soon as it's
inconvenient to them as soon as it comes
down on them so Ken Paxton uh jumping
into a truck and running away Beyond
parody but they're for Law and Order
don't don't forget that guys they're for
Law and Order let me know your thoughts
you can find me on Twitter at dpacman we
are going to take a very quick break and
be right back